let me ask you politically have you
always been where you are right now
politically
no i was a liberal democrat now i'm a
libertarian when did you switch what
year
probably 20 years into my career
so 1899. and what caused you to flip
89 was who reagan it wasn't politics it
was
gradual i mean i call it an epiphany in
my
book where i talk about it but it was
slow we would do stories we would take a
tv to 20 repair shops
with a one loose part and
18 would say oh loose part no charge
and two would say oh we'll have to keep
it over the weekend and they'd charge
you 200 bucks
we'd come back and i'd say well would
you ever cheat people like this
oh no we'd never do that oh yeah watch
this and i'd press the record
also the play button and show what how
they had cheated
us and they were embarrassed and it was
good tv
and so then the politicians would call
oh that was really interesting we're
going to solve that we're going to
create a
department of consumer affairs in oregon
and they did and i was so proud young
john stossel was being paid attention to
with these
important politicians and they were
going to
solve the problem but we'd do the story
again
and get the same result it's the free
market most people are honest they want
repeat business the way to get really
rich in a free market is to treat your
customers well
a couple people cheat but
the same result so what was the
department of consumer affairs doing
i look into that they have a dreary
government building where there are a
bunch of bureaucrats
licensing tv repair shops and car repair
shops too we did it for that
and people intuitively like that we
license drivers we license dogs it makes
us feel
safer but it doesn't make us safer it
just
adds layers of paperwork to go through
so if you
are an immigrant who doesn't speak
english maybe you go black market and
then you can be extorted by the police
or you have to worry that you will be
you don't build up your business
or you gotta when you're in a low margin
business
spend your money on a lawyer and they
cost a fortune
just to explain the complicated rules
and you go down there you renew it every
year
it just adds layers and layers of
sclerosis on top of to over-regulate so
you notice
so so you notice let me paraphrase what
you're saying and see if
i'm saying it correctly so you're you're
a liberal democrat
you're going out there holding small
businesses accountable you're making
those videos oh i got you and you know
all of a sudden they're embarrassed but
it's great for tv and people are
watching it oh john is watching out for
us he's looking out for us
and then all of a sudden you flip
because you notice that consumer affairs
isn't doing the best thing for the
people it's making the process even
slower than you
from your experience you said i'm i'm
this doesn't make any sense to me
all correct except for the all of a
sudden because i saw that the regulation
wasn't working got it
so i started reading the conservative
media
but they seemed to want to police the
bedroom and police the whole world and i
didn't like that
and i discovered reason magazine and
libertarianism and
it was a whole new way of thinking about
the free market
and i lapped this up and i thought oh
i've seen the light i'm a board again
free market person
and i've naively assumed that other
people who saw what i saw
would flip too but they
don't some people just cannot get
comfortable with the benefits of
competition
and markets why do you think that is why
do you think competition like
you know there's there's some words
today that is is a curse word today
like i'm hiring a uh i'm doing an
interview the other day and i
uh ask uh you know some questions when
i'm hiring somebody you know and i say
so what do you think about competition
what do you think about capitalism
i just ask a basic open-ended question
i'm putting my kids at a private school
here in
in florida and i interview the people
that are bringing kids in so what do you
think about capitalism they start
smiling
what why why why are you smiling what's
funny you must be a pro
such and such and i'm just asking you
what do you think about capitalism how
do you guys teach capital some to your
kids
well we teach the benefits of socialism
and we teach the benefits of capitalism
and we let the kids decide i said you
realize your tuition is 32 000
only a capitalist can afford your school
so if you're going to do a socialism and
the benefits of it you're going to have
no parent that can afford to pay
the socialistic tuition because the
socialists can't afford to pay your
tuition
to your school but capitalism has become
a curse ward
competition the capitalists are all
guilty about their money and have no
idea that it was
free markets that made it for them so
the rich capitalists are eager to
have their kids taught socialism are you
being sarcastic or no
they don't get it they they live in the
world where they don't
see the basic principles that made the
money they see the ruthless part they
say yes some people fail some people
they kind of get embarrassed by do you
think yes
i had a guy named ernie one of our uh
marketing directors see i asked him i
said so ernie he went to berkeley
and you know african-american played for
cal
and he came out and all of a sudden one
day he switches flips
thomas soul guy you know thomas you've
done a video on thomas just recently
thomas so
classic soul school choice and then he
flips i said let me ask you a question
why do
so many billionaires vote the way that
they do he says because they feel guilty
i said guilty for what
what do you feel guilty about do you do
do they all of a sudden
think that they are somehow better than
others do they somehow think that they
have some special gifts that others
don't have so
hey it's not you know i have a unfair
advantage over the average person
because i'm smarter than you
what is it what do you think it is in
terms of voting maybe they're voting
that they don't want to be
anti-immigration
or they don't want foreign wars or they
don't want
tariffs it's not all about markets
got it yeah i just wonder right now you
know on
uh you know even even what happened uh
two weeks ago with uh the georgia union
for amazon right you were probably fine
liking the result the media was going oh
they're going to unionize it so they're
so unhappy here
and they got killed and they got killed
but here's the kicker
the day before union lost i don't know
if you follow this the day before union
lost
bezos went in the public and said i
support the increase in taxes
he says i don't think we're paying
enough taxes so do you
think i'm speculating you've been around
this longer than i have do you think
behind closed doors a phone call was
made saying hey
just a few years ago when obama was
raising taxes
obama got buffeted to agree to say i'm
not paying enough taxes remember the
whole story about i'm only paying 15
and i shouldn't be paying as little
taxes i should be paying more taxes and
buffett came out and said and then obama
said
if buffett thinks we should raise taxes
why do the rest of the rich people have
a problem with it right do you think
this is a playbook to say
you're not going to do union we'll give
it to you but you got to go out there
and say it's okay to raise taxes because
if you agree with it
we're going to get others to vote for it
what do you think no
i don't think those phone calls happen i
think
it happens naturally because he's a
little guilty and he wants to be liked
and he can afford to pay more taxes do
you think he actually wants to be like
do you think he feels guilty that's
something you think is going on in
bezos's
i think everybody he wants to be liked
he's got
security guards i assume because they're
crazy people who
are so angry about the wealth disparity
they mark zelda
spends 25 million dollars a year on
security
and you know that's a shame but
the wealth disparity does drive people
to do that
the evil part on bezos side i think
is that he comes also came out and said
and
i pay all my workers 15 minimum wage and
there should be a law that everybody
should
and if he wants to do it fine he can
afford to because he's got the
technology to automate
but it's a business trick for the big
company to come and say yeah
everybody should pay the high wages that
i pay
because then he doesn't have to compete
with the people who will hire
at-risk kids and give him a first job
and that's just
he must know how evil that is and that's
just mean to do that by the way
essentially
bernie sanders pushing that whole month
when he was pushing bezos to raise
minimum wage to 15 bucks he was pushing
them and am
in walmart is who was pushing for
non-stop this was a couple years ago
when this was taking place so
essentially a
socialist sanders helped
a big company like amazon and walmart
yeah he's just economically stupid who's
that bernie
bernie economically stupid
it's very ignorant yeah it's a safe term
it's uh
going back you said and i asked you i
said reagan he said no it wasn't really
reagan i said all of a sudden you flip
you're like no that's the only part that
the story is not correct it was
gradually right who were some of the
names
that impacted you would you say sowell
friedman reagan who would you say some
of the names were
seoul friedman hazlett economics and one
easy lesson
[Music]
for kids i recommend to iron rand atlas
shrugged just a fiction story that
50 years ago she summed up the
bureaucracy we have now
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye